but I really want to ask mark because we
haven't really talked about this ever
before
is that I this idea of fear and courage
or fear in particular is that something
you push hard when you're working with
actors and getting performance is that
one of the elements or or does that just
emerge from other things if there's
something else that you say look for
this about the character more than
anything well it's interesting because
as I was listening to you I had some
thoughts which will answer your question
because number when you're talking about
the fear and the courage of the
character in the character and because
most of my work and you're working with
writers and screenplays most of my work
is working with directors and directors
working with actors so I'm working in
that world I'm working with this group
called directors this group called
actors and eventually there is the
character then eventually that character
is in a story and so as I was listening
to you I said yeah because what I'm
dealing with a lot before I even get to
the cat with your question about the
character and their fear and their
courage I'm dealing with the fear and
courage or a lack of courage of the
director and the actor forget the
character for a moment right in other
words a directors fear of even talking
to an actor you know the did a lot of
directors fear me too many directors
were afraid of actors and too many
actors are afraid of directors and it's
it's it's a disease that's been going on
ever since so a lot of what I'm dealing
with is dealing with a directors fear of
talking to AG with an actor and his
courage not as there's courage to talk
to an actor but his courage to feel that
he is capable of maintaining his
authority while collaborating with an
actor did you know we did to get over
you know there was the coach within
himself nothing nothing to do with
overpowering the actor then dealing with
the actor and then dealing with the
actors theater and the lot of this has
to do with control which is similar to
your characters
for the atmosphere which is the
directors fear - of giving up control -
many artists that terminate directors
and too many actors want to control
everything directors want to control the
whole film which is a big problem actors
want to control their performance which
is a big problem they should both give
up that and give over to the character
because that's all we're there for is to
create the character but not I'm not
there to direct I'm there to help an
actor create a character the actor is
not there to act the actors there to
allow the character to live and breathe
and then we get into eventually we get
into who is the character but I've got
to get past these other fears within
these artists called directors and
actors before I can even get to dealing
with the character in a in a deep way
and then yes we get once we can get
directors I can have to clarify this I
was gonna say directors directing actors
because my way of working with directors
is which Michael has seen is I have a
way of working with directors which is
called not directing I'm a way of
working with actors not directing the
actor stop directing the actor and
totally stop it and direct only the
character in fact there's a way this
technique I have a shudder as you've
seen shutting down the character's brain
I can shut the cat the actor I'm sorry
shutting down the actors brain this way
of talking to the character so that the
actors brain will actually shut down and
the character's brain will take over so
then the character can emerge and then
once I'm inside I can get inside the
character very fast within less than a
minute get inside the character and then
what I'm stimulating inside the
character is the fears that exist within
the character based on the script as I
understand it and then hopefully it's
also stimulating the source of possible
potential courage to deal with all the
elements that are in the script do you
link those two things I mean if you have
an actor which I assume is most of the
time who is afraid to let go and give
the performance do you use that real
fear that they have
to connect it with the nectar sphere
there's that oh no no no no if I you
because if I try to use that fear that
I'm stimulating that fear then what I'm
doing good point
no what I'm doing is through this this
whole tech in my technique of working
with actors with the interrogation
process what you've seen is I'm
bypassing that fear by diminishing it I
just bypass it by diminishing the actor
then suddenly the fear will go away the
actors fear the actors real fear biggest
fear is they'll do a bad job the actors
biggest fear that they won't give a good
performance they won't please the
director they won't please the writer
they won't please anybody nothing's
gonna they won't please themself so what
I have to do is bypass all of those
fears mmm and actually take them off the
table rather than dealing with them but
that's it and then the courage that I
have to stimulate within the actor which
is not that ironically not that hard to
do the courage to trust me in other
words which is giving up control trust
me that I will I as the director will
take them where they need to go I will
the director will help them create their
game and then once they do that then
what happens is we could show you
sometime this what happens is the
character emerges and the actor usually
an actress I've done this with are
amazed because they said after it's done
they go oh I didn't have to do anything
I said no you don't you don't have to do
anything when actors realize that when
they actually portraying the character
they have to do so little in fact most
of the work a lot of actors do get in
the way of the process because they try
to control the process by acting by
thinking and I could shut down the
acting and I can shut down the thinking
and I can let the character think and
like the character behave you know and
I'm interesting the characters behavior
not the actors behavior it's not just
amazing to the actor it's amazing to
watch I think one of the reasons that we
really wanted or one of the reasons I
anyway really wanted to do this event
with Mark that we've been talking about
this beyond collaboration is because
even though we've known each other for
decades
I had never actually seen him teach one
of his class and he classes and he did
an event at the Directors Guild and
demonstrated this process he was just
talking about and it is astonishing to
watch because I who don't have any
experience in the directing side of this
I'm all about story and script I always
imagined the director would say okay now
you should walk over that way or you
should hold your hand here or or give it
more give it less and it's it's amazing
because he doesn't really talk to the
actor at all except in the very
beginning he just as quickly as he can
starts talking to the character in in
inside the skin of that actor and
bringing that character out by directly
engaging and then you see how that
brings out a performance that is just
astonishingly better than the one that
preceded it just because he was able to
connect that directly it's it's it was
just a wonderful thing to experience and
I think will be a wonderful thing for
the screenwriters who come to this event
to get to see because it's not
completely disconnected it's the writer
even in writing and creating those
characters has to be able to get to a
level that they could theoretically are
inside their head converse with their
character know their character well
enough I mean I've often read scripts by
writers and ask them questions about it
well well is the does this character
have a college degree or or what what
scares this person or whatever it might
be and they don't know all they thought
about is well I know my character has to
stop this serial killer and I think that
when writers can see you do that it's
really going to click into wow I could
actually be doing that with my writing I
could be going deeper with the character
in engaging them more directly in in my
head anyway in the creative process
you